time to count up the trades because the
trade deadline came and went yesterday
at four eastern without much happening
what a shock
what a shock that the bulk of the trade
activity was last week when teams could
get the guys in the fold due to the
covet 19 protocols
and have them for week nine i have a
feeling
more than a feeling that that dynamic
kept teams here's the problem any
negotiation both sides have to
to move to their bottom line at the same
time so the two circles on the venn
diagram can can just all they have to do
is touch right and you get a deal
and when you have some teams thinking
that last week as a practical matter was
the deadline
some teams thinking now we can push into
tuesday it's harder to do a deal yes
it's harder to get you know you're
talking about guys and there's a lot of
ego
and machismo and certainly and they
don't want to be able to see if they're
losing yeah
right right and and you get got people
who are hard-headed and they don't go to
their bottom line so i think that's one
of the big reasons why there weren't
more deals may have been one of the
reasons why
teams like the texans and packers chris
couldn't come to an agreement
on receiver will fuller i don't know how
serious the packers were
i think the texans were motivated to
find someone to take his eight-figure
salary off the books
right because number one he's never
quite
lived up to the first round pedigree
now he was one of three straight
receivers taken in 2016.
he's the only one still in the league
the other two were josh docks and el
quan treadwell now somebody may be on a
practice squad somewhere but
wilford is the only one contributing but
even then he's been injured a lot he's
never had a thousand yard
receiving season and i don't get the
impression that there was anyone other
than the packers that was even thinking
about trading for willful no no neither
neither have i and even people i reached
out to
just around the league to see if they're
getting any inklings or anything like
that that seemed to be the only name or
real action out there yesterday
certainly i mean i'm guessing and again
i don't know this just like you right
now
hopefully we'll hear i'm guessing the
texans were probably asking for too much
from green bay
you know and and i'm a little surprised
by that
but i'm guessing and i'm guessing maybe
green bay didn't want to
give up a whole lot because of the
things you've said you know his his
injury history hey sure the salary
and then do you really want them long
term
after this year what is the real deal
here you know that's the that's the
thing that
a team like green bay has to you know
come to terms with
hey finally yeah we'll trade you
but what are we gonna get back that's a
great meme that really is
uh that's spanky from our game is that
what it is
yeah see my guess is 98 of the people
who see that have no idea what that is
that is spanky i i knew i was one of the
little raspberries
type of guys i knew that i just i had no
idea the name or anything like that
but i think ultimately that's what holds
up these type of deals especially with a
guy like will fuller last year the deal
wait we'll give you something we don't
want to give you too much we're not
assured he's going to be here that long
you know this might just be a few games
[ __ ] has an injury history
i think all those things play into it uh
as a guy who sits here in roots of aaron
rodgers
yeah i'm a little disappointed you know
that i love aaron rodgers
and i want to see him with weapons
because i want to see
him have a chance when he gets to the
playoffs to win some shootouts and maybe
he can carry the team that way
if he has one more weapon and he doesn't
so we'll see where it goes
and we played the video yesterday and
it's great to have not just sound but
also
the facial expressions it was the smile
on the face been a lot of talk about
that over the years
yeah hey ryan hey ryan you know we
talked about that from time to time
that's an excellent question ryan i'm
glad you raised it
i have no role in personnel but it is
quite
the excellent question right you keep
asking the tough questions
uh so look they're going to go with what
they have and
there was a suggestion to report
whatever from adam schefter the other
day was on pat mcafee show saying that
the packers checked in on antonio brown
i don't think that matters i think
antonio brown was a done deal behind the
scenes to tampa bay for nothing
weeks but months but uh yeah
obviously they need help and you know i
this gets into the
humanity of this sport and
the reality that you know sometimes
someone will resist doing something
because if they do it or try to do it
they are in a roundabout way admitting
that they maybe
should have done things differently
earlier yeah like you know brian gooda
koontz
yeah if brian goody comes goes out and
gets a receiver now
people are going to say why the hell
didn't you just draft one yeah why are
you buying the balance of wilford's
contract when this year had an
unprecedented number of talented
receivers
you could have had chase claypool goodie
and you have traded up to get jordan
love what are you thinking so
you're almost refusing to acknowledge
that there's a need
in order to avoid the questions of why
the hell didn't you just draft a guy
instead of
taking on an eight-figure salary for a
guy that you're going to rent for half a
season
i i i worried about the same aspect
coming down to the trade line i mean
when we when you thought about
specifically green bay
that was one of the thoughts that came
to your head yeah okay they're gonna
make the trade
but oh you're gonna have to answer a lot
of questions about
you made a trade you obviously needed a
receiver why
you know wasn't that done earlier in the
draft like you said or in free agency
anything like that
and i i do think that's a little bit of
the politics of the position
regardless of the situation doesn't
matter anything
like it's a real issue in green bay it's
a real issue for a team that is viewed
as one of the best teams in our league
there is not a second receiver
on the football team there's not i mean
there's nobody hey look the stats for
the green bay packers devonte adams of
course
leads the team in receiving and then
it's robert tonyan
and second and then it's williams yep oh
here's the receivers
this is the receivers but they're not
even the you know jamal williams
he's got more receptions than marquez
valdez scandling
i mean alan lazard is the second third
receiver i know he's been injured it's
13 receptions
so here's rogers and devonte adams and a
bunch of no names
trying to make the offense move and yeah
aaron jones is a good player and all
those type of things but we've seen here
the last few weeks green bay's defense
is not super bowl caliber
you know they got a solid pass
protecting offensive line
and they have a good offensive system
it's not great
they have a super bowl quarterback and
that was their biggest chip in the game
and they've done nothing to really
support him to help
you know the super bowl quarterback then
therefore take it to a super bowl team
and to me
they dropped the ball in that big time
this whole year 2020 the whole calendar
year they dropped it
you know the packers are one of the
teams that this whole cova dynamic at
the trade deadline
shouldn't have affected because they
play thursday night
even if they could have gotten worse
yesterday
in a normal year what's he going to do
for you
in two days not much so he was a week 10
guy
anyway unless they would well they would
have gotten the deal done
a while ago to have him available for
the vikings game but he's a guy that if
you add him to the mix and he's healthy
he's going to make that green bay
offense better and he's going to
position that team
to have a deeper run into the postseason
right it's a no-brainer now they just go
forward with what they have and again
they play thursday night
in santa clara against the 49ers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports